[Zene]
üdvözlök minden kedves hallgatót a
következő vendégem széles ferenc aki
számítógépes grafikusként lehetne egy
szóban összefoglalni de tudom hogy nem
szereti ha így foglalják össze mert
ennél sokkal színesebb nemrég töltött
ecadorban hat hetet és egy grafikus
rajznaplót vezetett közben ami a
liget.ro jelent meg eddig öt rész jelent
meg és a hatodik rész hamarosan látható
lesz izgalmas beszélgetés volt magáról
ecuadorról az útról udvarhelyről ahonnan
elindult és magáról ecuadorról is
beszélgettünk egy kicsit de amit
számomra ennél izgalmasabb az a miértje
hogy miért utazott el mit tanult ezáltal
és hogy hogyan látja a kicsi városunkat
ezután az út után tartsatok velünk
üdvözöllek téged ferenc itt a
stúdiónkban és a mai nap nagyon izgalmas
dolgokról fogunk
beszélgetni úgy ahogy mondtad nem nagyon
lehet téged bemutatni egyszerűen hogyha
most nagyon egy címkét rád kéne húzni
akkor számít gépes grafikus címkét
húznék rád de vagyis húztál te volna
magadra hogyha ha ha nagyon-nagyon
szükség lenne valahogy megnevezni téged
de amúgy nem is szereted hogy te
meglegyél nevezve valamilyen formában és
azz azt hiszem hogy azért lesz egy
nagyon izgalmas beszélgetésünk mert már
most nagyon nagyon nagyon sok oldaladat
felvillantottad és szeretnék egy kicsit
beszélgetni ezekről mind és persze ezt
így körbejárjuk ezt a témát de a legfőbb
téma amiről fogunk beszélgetni az a
nemrégben
nemrég megélt kalandod hogy elmentél
ecuadorba és ott hat hetet töltöttél ha
jól emlékszem
igen egy másfél hónap más egy egy másfél
hónapot töltöttél eredetileg egy hónapra
volt tervezve de
időközben volt egy olyan lehetőség amit
nem nagyon akartam kiadyni úgyhogy még
egy két hét rákerül hogy jutt el egy a
te szavaiddal élve egy hétköznapi
figura
ecuadorba hát felül a repülőre nyilván
mivel hogy úszni azért annyira nem tudok
hogy ezt a nagy patakot ami kettőnk
között van azt át tudjam úszni
ez egy hosszú történet valamilyen
szinten tehát hogyha most nem akarok
visszamenni egészen a kőkorszakig meg a
dinókig a lényeg az hogy unokatestvérem
akivel sok időt töltöttem együtt
gyerekként ő mindig is ilyen biológus
beállítottságú volt megvan az a
kattanása hogy hogy hogy bármi a ami él
mozog az őt rettenetesen érdekli mikor
kőkök voltunk akkor is ugyanez volt
időközben mindenkinek történt az élete
jobbra-balra és az őé pont úgy történt
hogy ez a meggyőződése hogy minden ami
él mozog az őt érdekli ez
végül odavezette őt hogy hogy
biológusként helyezkedett el és olyan
hatalmas szerencséje volt hogy az
eekvadori kormány pont abban az
időszakban amikor ő a doktoriát írta a
békákból békákból ez tágfogalom de
maradjunk annyian hogy bék-ákból akkor
meghirdetett egy programot aminek az
volt a neve hogy prométeus és az volt a
lényege hogy bármilyen eekvadori egyetem
hogyha szüksége volt külső szakemberekre
akkor azokat meghívhatta nagyon-nagyon
jó körülmények között és ezt a ezt a
meghívást ezt közzétették mindenféle
egyetemeken neki meg a az egyik tanára
akivel együtt dolgozott az felhívtare a
figyelmét és egyszer csak hiphhapotoltak
ecvadorba ecvadorral azt kell tudni hogy
a aki aki herpetológiával tehát
kétéltűekkel foglalkozik azoknak ez egy
szent hely tehát ez egy megka
gyakorlatilag tehát aki aki békával
kígyóval foglalkozik azok ott ott
teljesen megőrülnek ettől az egész
dologtól és akkor így történt az hogy
ezt 10 évvel ezelőtt ők kimentek ebbe a
prometeus projekttel ő és a felesége
diána és
időközben az egyik egyetemen nyílt egy
egy lehetőség hogy ott maradjanak és
nyilván éltek vele mivel hogy ez nekik a
legfontosabb csak ezzel foglalkoznak
csak ez érdekli őket úgyhogy ott
maradtak és a 10 év alatt folyamatosan
ahányszor találkoztunk egy-két évente
mikor hazajöttek akkor mindig ez volt
hogy gyere kiézd meg mert borzasztóan
hatalmasan nagy királyhely én meg mindig
persze hogy ne hát akármikor hát kilépek
ecadorra végül is itt van a sarkon tehát
bötfalva után balra ott van ecuador
úgyhogy ez így húzódott egészen a tavaly
mikor itthon voltak akkor mutatott
rákérdeztem hogy akkor tényleg mit
csináltok tehát mivé telik el egy nap és
mondta hogy terepeznek ami egy
tágfogalom mi az hogy terepeztek vagy ez
mit jelent és mutatott fényképeket arra
hogy hogy néz k egy ilyen terepezést
mikor kiszállnak terepre és akkor azt
mondtam hogy oké akkor most már tényleg
meggyőztél ott a hely és akkor repülő
pufelő leszálltam már is eekvadorban
voltam körülbelül ez dióéban dióébaan é
leegyszerisítve azért mert ganítom hogy
nem volt ilyen egyszerű felülni egy
repülőre és nem volt ilyen egyszerű
megszervezni hogy hat hétre itt tud
hagyni a munkálat meg a
kötelezettségeért ezt ez tényleg így
volt hogy előtte sokat kellett készülj
azért hogy ezt meg tudd szervezni
jellemzően a dolgaimat
úgy csinálom hogy ilyen eléggé
rögtönözve tehát ilyen hirtelen
felindulásból mert hogyha elkezdek
gondolkozni bármin is akkor akkor abból
nem lesz már semmi jellemzően valami
olyasmivel foglalkozok ami ami a
hülyeség a köz közértelembe vett
hülyeség kategóriájába esik ezeket csak
úgy lehet hogy hirtelen felindulásb
úgyhogy egyik este megvettem a
repülőjegyet ennyi tehát hogy nem cosz a
feleséged mit szólt
ők már tisztában vannak ezzel a ezzel az
apró kis kábelezési hibával hogy hogy ha
valamit akarok csinálni akkor azt
csinálom nem egyszerű nem egyszerű tehát
hogy nyilván családapaként meg férként
gyanítom hogy azért felelősséget kell
vállalja ezekért a dolgokért tehát hogy
meg kellett szervezd ezt az utat hogy
megvetted rendben a repülőjegyed de a
hiányodat pótolni meg gyanítom a
munkahelyen is majd valamilyen
szempontból a valam vagy kellett pótolni
vagy kicsit mesélnél erről hogy milyen
felkészülési szakasszal járt ez hogy el
tudj menni hat hétre
hát
végül
is az nem volt egyértelmű hogy milyen
lesz majd a netkapcsolat mennyire
lehetek mennyire leszek elérhető de
szerencsére ez ezér eléggé rendben volt
tehát egész végig elérhető voltam volt
is egy olyan projekt amelyiken közben
dolgoztam mivel hogy vittem magammal
laptopot
a családdal azzal napi szinten
online kapcsolatot tartottam tehát
reggel mindig ez volt a műsor hogy mikor
felkeltem kávéztam akkor ugye
beszélgettem velük
úgyhogy ez a része ez nagyjából így
történt ami amire nem lehet felkészülni
de te is családapaként ezt tudhatod az a
pillanat amikor el kell vágjad haj csak
ideiglenesen is ezeket a szálakat amik a
családhoz kötnek tehát volt egy konkrét
pont a
az egész utazásban amikor amikor azt
kellett mondjam hogy oké akkor ez a az
utolsó integetés
nagyon még most is meghadódok hogyha
erre gondolok de
ez egy nagyon nagyon kemény döntés mi
ilyenkor tehát konkrét esetben az jutott
eszembe hogy azok akik távolálljon tőlem
hogy felfedezőként tekintsek magamra de
akik mit tudom elmentek északi sarkat
meg jáárni meg ilyesmi hogy ők ők ők
hogy hogy tudták otth hagyni a
családukat mondjuk ez egy nagyon-nagyon
éres és durva hasonlat de de valamilyen
szinten ez volt a leg legnehezebb az
egészben nem a repülőjegyvásárlás vagy a
14 órás út hanem az a pillanat amikor
amikor amikor kiemelkedtem a hétköznapi
rutinomból és átkapcsoltam abba hogy
akkor úton vagyok akkor most innentől
kezdve ami az fog történni ez ez mikor
történt meg amszterdamban nem hanem ez
amikor a repülőg repülő a transzferre
mikor felültem tehát a a kisbusz ami
felvitt bukarestbe amikor felültem az
volt az a pont ahol ahol úgy
gondolkoztam hogy én zer leszállok tehát
az egy nagyon-nagyon nehéz pont nagyon
nehéz meglépni az ember próbálja lazára
venni de nem nem lehet családapaként
mindenki ezt megérteti hogy ez hogy
történik szóval elindult a kalandod és
amszterdamon keresztül ugye ot volt egy
átszállás és onnan hova érkeztél
amszterdamból kitóba érkeztem kitóból
pedig autóval lementünk
loháig unokatestvéreméik ők lohában
élnek a lohai egyetem tehát az utplnek a
tanárai
és értem jöttek kitóba mi mel hogy
amikor mentem akkor rengeteg olyan hír
volt hogy ugye lövöldöznek ecvadorban
meg jaj istenem vége a világnak
megmondom őszintén kicsit azért bennem
is össze volt szorulva hogy
azért utazgatunk utazgatunk de azért
csak felelősséggel ez amúgy az ez miért
miért lövöld bandaháborúk vagy igen igen
igen igen bővebben kifejtem a lényeg az
hogy hogy a média az ugye általában
mindent sötétebb színekbe fest le régió
vannak tehát loha teljesen teljesen
nyugodt teljesen biztonságos éj 2kor
nyugodtan lehet sétálni abszolút
abszolút biztonságos hely lent a
partoknál tehát gill magasságában ott
kicsit izgalmasabb a dolog kitóba is
talán de nem jellemző
úgyhogy a a lényeg az hogy utánam jöttek
autóval és akkor egy egy ilyen két-három
napos assiszem három nap alatt mentünk
le loháig mert
elég hosszú az út is meg közben
megnéztünk egy csomó mindent pontosabban
meg próbáltunk nézni egy csomó mindent
mert ugye
a ilyen nagyon esős borus idő volt ami
ez volt az első olyan pont ahol
szembesültem azzal hogy a az egzotikum
amit kialakítunk a fejünkben bármilyen
helyről az nem feltétlenül fedi a
valóságot tehát ugye ecador mint a
nevében is benne van trópusi orzágnak
számít tehát hogy ugye az a az egyenlítő
van trópusi országnak számít de én meg
ugye az andok tetejére érkeztem és az
andok tetején ereszkedtünk lefelé tehát
ez egy 3000 m magas hegyvonulatról
beszélünk 2000 mteren vannak
gyakorlatilag az utak és az egész három
nap alatt folyamatosan esett az eső köd
volt a van egy ilyen rész amit úgy
hívnák hogy avenida de losvulkán a bocsi
a spanyolságomat
ahol lehet látni vagy hét vulkánt
amelyikek közül van amelyik aktív de mi
egyet se láttunk a a a csimborasszót
láttam egy három percig körülbelül
annyira el elv anir el igen és az a kész
utána a vége volt úgyhogy ebből a hat
hétből hány napot töltöttetek konkrétan
úton
expedíción
hát napra pontosan nem tudom megmondani
körülbelül 90 sa 90%-át úthon voltatok
ehhez azt kell tudni hogy az ők életük
józsefék unokatestvérmknek az élete az
az úgy néz ki hogy
ők reggel ugye felkelnek bemennek az
egyetemen megtartják az óráikat
ugye folyamatosan kutatásokat végeznek
azokkal foglalkoznak dokumentációk és a
többi és a többi és utána este 6:00-tól
általában terepeztünk tehát volt amikor
közvetlen közelbe mentünk tehát ilyen
egy-két órás útra és akkor illyan é 12
felé értünk vissza mert a az a másik egy
amire nem voltam először felkészülve
hogy ugye itt ez az egész dolog éjszaka
történik mert a a békák kígyók ezek
jellemzően éjszakai állatok meg éjszaka
aktívak északai állatok akkor ezeken
felül pedig voltak ilyen három-négy
napos kiszállásos rendszerek ahol elm
mentünk
messzebbre és ott botorkáltunk a ott az
erdőben vagy fönn a paramóban de hogy
hogy folyamatosan szinte ezt mondhatnám
volt persze nyilván olyan olyan napok is
voltak amikor amikor loohába sétáltam
tehát a városb de jellemzően ez volt
hogy hogy kint voltunk terepen ahogy ők
mondják a loha amúgy milyen mint város
hogy tudjam elképzelni egy
kedves kis város
méretre hát ilyan szentgyörgy kategória
körülbelül csak itten ugye egészen más
az elrendezése a városoknak merthogy ez
egy tekenő amiben loha van de és kitek
veszik körbe igen de nagyon magas hegyek
veszik körbe ezért van egy saját kis
mikroklímája ami olyan mintogyha
folyamatosan tavasz lenne tehát a az eső
az megeredel áll megeredel áll tehát
amikor kisit a nap akkor nagyon erősen
süt
beborul tehát hogy folyamatosan változik
eekvadorban nem fárasszák magukat
időjárásjelentés az emberek mert nem
nincs értel nincs értelme annyira
változékony ugye a hegyek miatt hogy
most nem lehet a len a partokon meg ugye
állandóan ugyanaz a hőmérséklet
és a másik ami érdekes volt ezekben a
városokban hogy mind ilyen ilyen
hálószerűen vannak elrendezve tehát hogy
hogy nem úgy vannak az utcák mint nálunk
hogy össze-vissza kacskaningóznak hanem
a városközpont az gyakorlatilag egy
négyzetháló
a 70-es években fejlődött egy nagyot a
város akkor szép lassan kezdtek
kiépítkezni az oldal tehát ennek a
tekenőnek az oldalára is ami azt
eredményezte hogy olyan utcák vannak
ahol azért jól el lehet fáradni míg az
ember kimegy a gyerekek ott nem nagyon
fotballoznak mert ugye ha a labdát
valaki kirúgta akkor a napá átelik amíg
lemennek
visszahozzák ez a ez a hálórendszer ezt
gondolom hogy a
a még a a kolonizáló idejéből származik
mertogy arra van kiépítve tehát hogy
látszik hogy tervezett igen igen igen
igen
kissé idegesítő az elején merthogy nincs
tájékozódási pont ezek ezek megint
megint érdekes helyi jellegű dolgok
hogy nálun udvarhelyen meg általában a
mi városainkban valahol van egy magasabb
torony domb valami ami az ember érzékel
folyamatosan nagyjából irányba tartja
itt meg ez a négzetháló miatt
minden ugyanolyannak tűnik hogy itt már
jártam nem balra kell befordulni jobbra
kell befordulni és a a az épületek miatt
nem nagyon látszanak körbe a a hegyek se
hogy hogy az legyen de a helyiek azok
zsigerből meg tudják mondani hogy
merrefelé van észak merrefelé van dél
üüm tehát hogy vagy nem merrefelé van az
irányokat meg tudják mondani mert van is
egy ilyen közlekedési szabályuk hogy az
észak-délnek előnye van a
kelet-nyugattal szemben most idegenként
ez azért így eléggé meglepetésként éri
az ember de amúgy a közlekedésük az az
egy az egy az egy különmét megér tehát
hogy ők is kicsit úgy vannak vele mint
az udvarhelyiek hogy hogyha jobban
megnyomom a dudát akkor magasabbra
emelkedik az autón vagy teleporter van
benne vagy nem tudom tehát hogy ez a
dudálgatás megy de nem agresszív tehát
inkább a az index helyett dudát
használnak erre kell gondolni ez
egyfajta kommunikációs eszközö így van
így van bárki megy el az úton akkor az
az dudálgat hogy helló jövök tehát az ha
valaki indexet használ akkor az már
gyanús ott valami nem valami mé
használni ind igen ha ha előre akarnak
valakit engedni
például a nagy utakon akkor nem jobbra
indexelnek le hanem balra amiről nem
lehet eldönteni hogy ő most tényleg
balra le fog térni vagy csak jelzi hogy
igen elmehetsz mellettem tehát ez
kamionoknál egy eléggé érdekes kérdés
amúgy vezettél is ott igen igen igen
igen
a benzin borzasztóan olcsó mivel ugye
olaj termelő vagy kitermelő ország és
ezenfelül még az állam is ö támogatja a
benzinárakat
ellenben az oktám szám az ijesztően
alacsony
és valami tehát hogy hogy nagyon nagyon
furcsa ez a benzin ami annyit jelent
hogy hogy padlógáznál is az embernek az
az érzése hogy hogy áll az autó nincs
nincs ereje de mindenki így vezet
mindenki bőgőmotorral tehát hogy nem ha
ott kezdünk kapcsolgatni ahol az autó
ajánja akkor az biztos hogy meghal tehát
hogy hogy folyamatosan túlpörgetik a
motrokat az autóknak a motrait ezért a
forgalomnak is ilyen hangja van tehát
minthogyha mindenki kínozná az autóját
azon túl pedig nagyon korán elkezdenek
vezetni ezért nagyon jól kezelik az
autókat tehát hogy nem koccanást egyet
se láttam de koccanás közeli helyzetet
rengeteget nagyon jól vezetnek és
és odafigyelnek egymásra teht a
dudáláson kívül odafigyelnek egymásra
meg nem láttam integető kiabáló embert
az autóba tehát dudálnak egymásra de de
senki nem gesztikulál nem int be vagy
ilyesmit egyáltalán tehát a duda nem azt
jelenti mint nálunk hogy egy inkább az
hogy az érzelmeinknek a kifejezése igen
igen igen igen igen tehát ez a vámos
vámos gyerünk gyerünk gyerünk tehát
ennek ennek a jelzése két fajta dudálás
van a van a hosszú dudás van az a a a
tip-tip duda aminek az a lényege hogy
akkor vigyázz mert jövök vagy vagy
ilyesmi de hogy nem hadon ásznak
egymásnak
állítólag len gakillba szemkontaktussal
történik az egész dolog tehát hogy
összenéznek és akkor az alapján döntik
el hogy kinek van elsőbbsége ez csak
legenda de nyilván tehát hogy tényleg ez
van térjünk vissza akkor egy kicsit az
expedícióhoz is de nyugodtan hogyha
valamit még így megemlítenél szerintem
izgalmas lesz a hallgatók számára is
szóval
elmentél segíteni az unokatestvéreidnek
de ez valójában ez milyen segítségénn
hogy hogy tudjam ezt elképzelni hogy
mellettük voltál ez az egyik és a másik
pedig az hogy mit tudtál te hozzáadni
ehhez az expedícióhoz szerinted hát
inkább inkább semmit tehát a az hogy én
segítettem az az barokos túlzás habár
jó újrafogalmazok tehát én inkább azért
mentem oda hogy megnézzem hogy ők
effektíven csinálnak miközben ők
csinálták amit csináltak közben
magyaráztak mindenféléket mutattak meg
nekem ami laikusként fel sem tűnt volna
egy egy ilyen
terepezést dióéban úgy kell elképzelni
hogy
kimegyünk a helyszínre ezek a helyszínek
ezek különböző módszerekkel válogatják
ők ki ezeket kimegyünk a helyszínre
biztos hogy kerülött egy jó nagy hegy
előbb-utóbb mivel hogy ilyen a ilyen a
táj amin ugye felcaplatunk megvárjuk
amíg besötétedik és akkor utána kezdődik
a keresgélés
a amennyiben nincs békahang tehát hogy
ha nem énekelnek a békák akkor ez
gyakorlatilag egy fölöslegesen éltöltött
igazából az sem fölösleges túra mert
mindent rögzítenek rögzítenek
nedvességtartalmat magasságot nyomást
szélseességet mindent
mindent illetve a gps
útvonalat tehát amelyre jártunk ha
bármit észlelnek akkor azt gps ponton
bejelölik tehát hogyha találnak
valamilyen példányt akkor azt azt gps
ponton bejelölik attól függ hogy hogy
ismerős a példány nem ismerős a példány
akkor ha nem ismerős vagy olyan variáció
ami esetleg még nem egyértelmű akkor
azokat begyűjtik és
akkor ez az egész ugye fejlámpák fényébe
történik tehát egy egy egy kis gömböt
lát maga előtt az ember ami talán jó is
mert sokszor olyan helyen voltunk ahol
úgy voltam vele mikor mentünk föl
napvilág hogy hűha itt vissza is kell
jöljünk és
és a válasz az hogy igen igen igen é nem
árt hogyha az ember nem látja hogy hol
kell visszamenjen mert egy egy elvétett
lépés azért érdekes következményekkel
tud
járni és a az begyűjtik ezeket a
példányokat vagy hát ami mit találnak
ugye rögzítik hogy hol találták ha és
akkor utána visszamegyünk vagy a
szállásra vagy ugye a lakásba attól függ
hogy hogy hogy alakult és akkor neki is
fognak preparálni a példányokat mivel
hogy nagyon fontos az hogy hogy hogy
lehetőleg frissebben kerüljenek be od í
így van így van így van így van tehát ez
jellemzően ez volt volt amikor volt
amikor ugye élve sikerült bevinni a
példányt mertogy ez ezek nagyon érzékeny
kis állatok tehát mikor bék-ról
beszélünk ezt ezeket is tisztázni
szeretném mikor bék-ról beszélünk nálunk
jellemzően valami szemmel jól látható
szerkezetre gondolunk egy körülbelül
ekkora valamire ezek körülbelül ekkorák
tehát hogy nagyon kis kis állatocskák
a a hímek még kisebbek tehát ilyen egy
max két centis példányokról van szó amit
meg kell találni egy olyan sűrű
susnyásba hogy hogy egyszerűen
optikailag
felfogni nehéz azt a sok mindent ami ott
van azt a sok növényt egymásba fonódást
azt azt azt elsőre azér elég komoly
sokként éri az
embert és akkor meg kell találni ezeket
a kis bé békácskákat
íye a hallgatók kedvéért elmondom hogy a
liget prón jelent meg eddig öt részben
egy ilyen utinapló s hamarosan jön a
hatodik hamarosan jön a hatodik pont ezt
akartam kérdezni
szóval egy nem csak egy utinapló hanem
egy grafikus utinapló
és végigolvastam ezt az elmúltott részt
iss az az igazság hogy nagyon nagyon
izgalmasnak találtam egyrészt az ahogyan
írsz és a másik pedig ezek a grafikák
amiket készítettél ezek hihetetlenül
hihetetlenül jó grafikák és
amiket a a ami a a ami megfogalmazódott
ezzel kapcsolatban bennem hogy külön
kiemelted hogy azért nem fénykép azért
nem fényképeket készítettél mert nem
vagy fényképész viszont le tudsz
rajzolni olyan dolgokat amik számodra
fontosak amiket ki tudsz emelni így
grafikusként és ez ez nagyon nagyon
tetszik ez a gondolat mert azt hiszem
hogy a művészek azok akik megtanítottak
minket látni az emberiség történelmében
ők azok akik meglátnak olyan dolgokat
amiket ugye az emberiség nem és lassan
megtanítanak minket egy tájképre hogy
hogy a táj cél leet az ősember nem
gyönyörködött a napl lementében előtte
hanem próbálta túlélni a világot de a
ahogy elkezdtek megjelenni a a
festmények a a barlangrajzok a a
különböző műalkotások úgy megtanítják
más szemmel látni az emberiséget a
művészek és gyakorlatilag én ezt látom
ebben hogy azáltal hogy te
a te interpretációdba mutatod be
ecuadort az kiemel olyan dolgokat amiket
lehet fényképpen én sem látnék meg mert
minden mindennel összefügg úgy ahogy
mondtad hogy a a növényzet ott van már
isten tudja mióta egymásba ölelkezve és
végtelen komplexitással és amikor
ránézel azt se tudod hogy mi van ott
viszont egy gyakorlott szem könnyebben
ki tudja onnan a
békát szúrni szóval nagyon tetszett az
hogy grafikus napló és tényleg tényleg
nagyon jól írsz mindjárt felolvasok egy
részletet belőle de erre reagálnál- erre
a gondolatomra hogy hogy miért roajz é
miért nem fotó
meg ez hogy a művészek azok akik
megtanítanak minket látni
igen igen igen tehát
hogy
gyakorlatilag általában ami körülvesz
minket a valóság az egy annyira komplex
és összetett dolog annyi minden változó
van
hogy hogy ezt mi a hétköznapokban van
egy egyfajta lebutított formában
fogyasszuk nyilván nem lehet másként
tehát nem lehet elmenni úgy otthonról
hogy öt másodpercenként megállni és
elcsodálkozni azon hogy ez a kövecske ez
pont milyen jó szögben áll itt vagy hogy
a felhők milyen szépen mozognak és a
többi és a többi nyilván szükség van
arra hogy a hétköznapi rutinunkhoz
lebutítsuk hogy hogy így fejezzem ki
magamat a valóságot leegyszerűsítsük az
agyunk is így működik tehát egy csomó
mindent folyamatosan töröl mert ugye
kell a tárhely tehát
nem nem lehet mindent elmenteni
ugyanakkor meg hogyha ha van időnk
kedvünk lehetőségünk akkor egy egy
legegyszerűbb tárgynál egy legegyszerűbb
dolognál meg lehet állni és el lehet
gondolkozni azon hogy ennek milyen
összefüggései vannak most például itt
van ez a ez a kis kanál ami ami egy
hétköznapi tárgy soha nem gondolkozunk
el azon hogy akkor hát biztos vannak
emberek akik igen de hogy a
hétköznapokban nem gondolkozunk el azon
hogy ez
ez például inox hogyan készül az inox
egyáltalán hogy jutottunk el fejlődésünk
hogy jutott el odáig hogy ezt ezt ezt a
tárgyat létrehozzuk mitől lett ennyire
hétköznapi és ha kezdjük el
visszabontani akkor akkor eljutunk olyan
mélységekbe amit nem lehet a hét
hétköznapokban
követni tehát folyamatosan nem
gondolkozhatok azon hú kis kanál kis
kanál ismét hanem időről időre és a
rajzolásra is gyakorlatilag ez történik
hogy bizonyos dolgokra ránézünk azt azt
kiemeljük a fénykép ugyanezt tudja de
ahhoz meg érteni kell az egy az egy
külön műfaj nekem ez valahogy soha nem
ment tehát meg lehet nézni a több mint
20 gigányi fényképanyagot amit
készítettem borzasztó képek végtelen
halmaza amiken mikor eléveszem és
nézegetem akkor úgy vagyok hogy ne ez
biztos hogy nem az volt tehát nem itt
nem itt járt nem így nézett ki ott
nyilván
meg nem is volt megfelelő felszerelésem
de nagyon sok mindent
nem tud visszaadni a a fotó mint
olyan ami talán a rajzok sem például a
ecvadorban a az első ami ami igazán
megragadott az a tájnak a nyersessége
ezt ez csak így megfogalmazódott bennem
de nem lehet képeken ezt bemutatni
hacsak nem célirányosan nem nem tudom
nem igazán lehet ezeket képeken
bemutatni mit jelent ez hogy nyers a táj
a mikor a repülő megérkezett kitó fölé
az első érzése az embernek az hogy hűha
ez aztán mekkora város mivel h szét van
folyva az egész nem nagyon vannak magas
épületek mind mind alacsony épületek
vannak és akkor váratlanul ebbe a
hatalmas épülettengerben van egy
iszonyatos repedés mintogyha valaki
fejszível oda hasított volna egyet és
teli van ezekkel a város egyszerűen
ilyen a ilyen a a földrajza a dombok nem
lankásak mint nálunk hogy szépen íveltek
geológiailag az andok az egyik
legfiatalabb
hegyvonulat és ez látszik is tehát
kicsit úgy kell elképzelni mint
a régen volt ez a plafondíszítés amikor
a a gipszet felkenték a plafonra és egy
ilyen ez a zsíros kenyér minta egy
teszkával így le húzták és akkor olyan
kis sztalaktitok lettek belőle ugyanez
csak feje lefelé fordítva tehát hogy
hogy mint egy mint egy mint egy kafrács
hegyvöldgy hegy völgy hegyö és ezt
elsőre nagyon nehéz
elfogadni vagy így felfogni tehát hogy
elsőre elsőre ez a ez a vadság ez ez
nagyon de mindenhol szembesültem ezzel a
ezzel a
nyersességgel amit nem igazán lehet
képeken fotókon visszaadni h hogy hogy
elkalandozzak ember mindenesetre nekem
nagyon nagyon élvezetes volt végig
olvasni ezt a az ötrészes beszámolót
mert az az érzésem hogy hogy olyan módon
tudod látni a világot ahol ahogy ami
inspiráló amire miután elolvastam utána
jöttem rá hogy ezt ennél jobban én se
tudtam volna leírni viszont értek
valamit belőle hogy mit élhettél
által most felolvasok egy részt amit
akár máshonnan vagyis hogy bárhonnan
idézhettem volna de most pont ezt
idéztem ez az amikor terepjáróval vagy
nem tudom egy autóval mentet igen ez egy
duster egész pontosan ez egy duster
nagyszerű igen jakuri az első hely ahol
szembesülök azzal hogy a világ vége után
is vannak települések sőt még azon is
túl meredek domboldalba vágott keskeny
földúton vergődünk felfele miközben meg
vagyok győződve róla hogy az autó egy
része folyamatosan a szakadék fölött
lebeg ha ezen a domboldalon elvíjük az
irányt olyan mély szakadék vár ránk
amelyből nem hiszem hogy egyáltalán
összeszedik a
maradványainkat miután már eleget
rettegtem szembe jön velünk egy platós
terepjáró telezsúfolva emberekkel akik
teljes lelki nyugalommal nézik vissza
ahogy centizve elhalad a két jármű
egymás mellett még a szemem sem merem
behunyni nehogy ezzel a mozdulattal
megzavarjam az univerzum gyöngéd
egyensúlyát és bekerüljek a
hírekbe mindenesetre a közmondás é
zapszem elhelyezése komoly anatómiai
problémákba ütközött volna azokban a
pillanatokban
igen ez tényleg így volt valóban
egy csomó beidegződés van bennünk
európai emberekként
itt megy szembe az ember azzal hogy hogy
milyen én próbálok nyitott elmélyű lenni
amiből lehet a gyerekeimet is re nevelem
de ennek ellenére a hétköznapok
folyamatosan csíszolgatnak minket egy
olyan formára amivel nem is vagyunk
tisztában addig amíg amíg nem kell ezt
próbára tegyük és ecvador számomra pont
ilyen
volt szembesülnöm kellett azzal hogy
mennyi előítélet van bennem mennyire
mennyire borzasztóan európai vagyok
annak ellenére hogy kelet-európai de de
hogy mennyire európai a gondolkodásom
olyan távolságból összefolyik a
kelet-európai é igen ja számunra
abszolút számukra abszolút tehát hogy
hogy a a legnagyobb megtiszteltetés az
volt számomra hogy hogy nem gringo hanem
euróáó voltam tehát a gringo hogye ezek
az amerikaiak fehér vagy magas vagy
hozzájuk képes magas vagy szakál
szemüveg ez biztos hogy amerikai és
hogyha megértik hogy akkor nem nem nem
nem hanem transil a transilvania az
valamiért fura mód működött és mindig ez
volt az első kérdés hogy akkor vannak-e
vámpírok mondtam hogy nem igazán én
otthon tartok kettőt de ezek ilyen
energiavámpírok és az az érdekes
képességük hogy nem csak fizikai
közelségben képesek leszívni az
energiámat hanem interneten keresztül is
mint kiderült ezt eddig nem tudtam
de
hogy hogy hogy számukra ugyanúgy ahogy
számunkra délamerika egy távoli valami
megfoghatatlan koncepció számunra
ugyanígy európa egy ilyen gyűjtő fogalom
ezek a kis nemzetek jobbra balra őket
nem nem igazán tudnak mit kezdeni vele
európa egy ország
persze nyilván személyes
beszélgetésekkor ahol jobban elmélyül ez
a téma ottan ott körbe le ez járni
nekik a legjobban úgy lehet kifejezni
például a mi állapotunkat ami ami egy
érdekes dolog volt hogy náluk nagyon
sok indián van az indián kérdés ezek
ezek különböző törzsek de nem úgy
semmiképpen ahogy mi elképzelük hogy az
őserdőbe futkorásznak egy
ágyékkötővel hanem hanem közös nagy
közösségek és kicsit olyanok mint a
székelyek tehát hogy ilyen értelemben
hogy ők egy nagyobb rendszer kvisetével
meg így van ők egy egy nagyobb
rendszeren belül élik a saját világukat
a népviselet az változó tehát hogy
vannak ugye a szaraguró két két törzssel
kerültem kapcsolatba az egyik a suárok a
másik a szaragurók a suárokról nem lehet
megmondani hogy akkor ők most itt
indiánok vagy nem indiánok mert
gumicsizma rövid nadrág póló ez a ez a
népviselet meg machette és a a
szaragurók azoknak van egy jellegzetes
viseletük ők ők fönn azandokban vannak
és az az egyértelműen
felismerhető egy egy kalap meg egy ilyen
pelerinszerű dolog meg a nadrágjuk az
lábszár középig ér ami állítólag a
bányászmúlttal köthető össze tehát hogy
hogy így néznek ki a az indiánok de
ugyanakkor nagyon-nagyon fontos
faktor a eekvadorba mivel hogy bármilyen
döntést hoz a kormány azt kell
egyeztesse az indiánokkal az indiánok
érdekszövetségével tehát rengeteg törzs
van 40 fölé törzsről beszélhetünk vannak
nagyobb törzsek kisebbek de hogy egy
egyfajta érdekvédelmi szövetségük van és
és ők döntenek hogyha valami olyan
döntést hoz a kor anyaműen nincsenek
megelégedve akkor egyszerűen lezárják a
főutakat de nem úgy zárják le a főutakat
ahogy mi vagy itt európában hogy olyan
félingmdig morcosan hogy na jól van na
hanem hanem halál komolyan tehát ott nem
mozog semmi és az országnak olyan a
szerkezete hogy hogyha egy sávként
képzeljük el akkor három sáv van egymás
mellett van a tengerpartisában a a az
andok tehát a hegyvidék és van az
amazonia tehát ugye a a dzsungel rész
igazából szelva a helyes kifejezés a
dzsungel fogalom mindegy rögtön áttére
kerés és ezeken
a sávokon mindeniken végigalad egy fő
útvonal tronkálnak hívják ezeket ha
ezeket a főútvonalakat lezárják az
indiánok akkor akkor megáll a forgalom
tehát nem nem lehet semerre se eljutni
úgyhogy ők ezzel nagyon jól jól
játszanak nem élnek vissza vele meglepő
mód hanem tényleg csak fontos
helyzetekben alkalmazzák de akkor
olyankor teljes elkötelezettsége
hónapokig akár képesek
bizonyos részeket lezárni tehát hogy nem
csak úgy hogy kimennek és csörömpölnek
hanem hanem érdekes formája a
demokráciának igen
ők nagyon ez egy másik minden más
nyilván de hogy a politikához való
hozzáállásuk az az egyrészt kötelező a
szavazás az országban másrészt pedig ők
is nagyon komolyan veszik ezt az egész
politikai dolgot de nem úgy mint mi hogy
a fociról ahogy beszélgetünk hanem a
saját helyi szintjüken tehát a a
képviselői szinten nagyon komolyan
veszik ezt az egész dolgot hogy ki a
képviselő és a képviselőik azok tényleg
ennek függvényében aktívak is vagy hogy
hogy a közösségnek a segítségére vannak
tehát hogy ez a része ez ez nagyon
nagyon hatékony náluk amúgy meg meg
végtelenül jámboremberek tehát hogy ez
egy ez egy nagyon
furcsa
kulturális konfliktus nem konfliktus
hanem erre el kellett eljen egy pár hét
amíg amíg amíg ez megfogalmazódott
bennem ez mit jelent hámborak ez azt
jelenti hogy nincs bennük agresszivitás
nincs bennük kegyetlenség nincs bennük
önzőség tehát ez ez nálunk európában a
mi régiónkban meg
pláné van egyfajta önmagunk felé hajlás
az emberekbe tehát hogy a a saját
érdekeink azért nagyon könnyen
legitimálnak olyan dolgokat amiket amúgy
ha szembesítenének velünk akkor azt
mondanánk hogy nem nem szó se lehet róla
de amint önmagunkról van szó akkor
hajlunk arra hogy kicsit kicsit
agresszívebbek legyünk
kicsit kanyorgósabb utakon járjunk és a
többi ez egyáltalán nincs meg bennük
tehát ilyen értelemben
jámborak jó példa a taxisok európában a
taxis fogalom az azért nagyon-nagyon
közel áll ahhoz hogy itten valahol lesz
egy kis pénzügyi görbíés nem pontosan
úgy fognak kinézni a dolgok mint az
elején ahogy
megegyeztük országja válogatja városa
válogatja de jellemzően taxiba ülni
európába az kicsit
ilyen náluk nem a taxi az egy
nagyon-nagyon fontos alapvető
közlekedési eszköz és végtelenül
pontosan visszaadnak városon belül
pontos díja van tehát konkrétan loohában
bárhova az egyik feléből a városnak a
másik felében másfél dollár tehát ez
ebből nem ezt nem is mérik ha ha
valahová kell menni akkor is
nagyon-nagyon pontosan adnak vissza de
ez a boltokban is ugyanígy történik
tehát sehol nem éreztem azt hogy akkor
én most ö
egy igen így van sehol nem éreztem
először megint az előítéletek hogy az
első nap kimentem a piacra és az volt az
érzésem mivel hogy ugye nem számítok
magasnak de csak kilógtam a a tömegből
az volt az érzésem hogy mindenki a
lehetőséget látja háhá itt van akkor ez
a elveszett fejű szemeges szakálas bohóc
akkor ezt éljük meg de nem egyáltalán
tehát hogy hogy semmilyen módon sehol
nem találkoztam ezzel hogy hogy ezzel
visszaéltek az életszínvonalat hogyan
érnád le furcsa mert hogy mertogy ők
ugye dollárt használnak és a dollárnak
az értékét nem tudtam belőni tehát
például a az elektronikai cikkek a
legegyszerűbb elektronikai cikkek is
iszonyatosan drágák tehát ha nem is
duplája a mi elektronogi cikinknek de de
20-25%-kal drágábbak
és viszonylag nezen beszerezhetők az
autók szintén iszonyatosan drágák de az
étel meg a közle a tömegközlekedés
nagyon-nagyon olcsó
a a lakhatás is egész érdekes
rendszerben van megoldva tehát hogy az
is főleg ugye egyetemistákkal beszéltem
akik a nekik az egyetemistáknak
jellemzően jutányos áron adják ki a
lakásokat tehát hogy
hogy az alapélet az az jóval olcsóbb
mint itthon ezt lehet mondani de amint
az ember egy kicsit már eltolódik a
luxus felé ami ami nálunk ugye
természetes tehát egy autó vagy hasonló
akkor ottan már már hatalmas különbségek
vannak például a szállodában egy szoba
10 dollár és ezek rendben lévő szállodák
nyilván vannak drágábbak is de hogy
főleg vidéken abszolút ez volt a az
alapár a a kaja tudom 3 dollárból
bőségesen lehet
enni nem dohányoznak ez a másik ami m mi
tehát hogy lassan rakódtak ezek bennem
össze hogy hogy mi az ami különbség a
nem dohányzás az tehát utcán senkit nem
láttam dohányozni a
szupermarketekben sehol nincs
dohányárusítás ilyen kis zúboltokba
árulgatnak itt-ott úgyhogy nem
egyáltalán nem dohányoznak az
alkoholfogyasztás is az is egy ilyen nem
egy nem nem úgy történik nem semmiképpen
nem semmiképpen nem
próbálkoznak sörreel nem nagyon sikerül
nekik az eekvadori sörök azokról hát
sajnos olyan jókat nem tudok mondani
de hogy hogy nem
nem nem jellemző az hogy hogy
alkoholizál ának a drogfogyasztás az
szintén egy egy olyan dolog ami amivel
nem foglalkoznak annak ellenére hugye
hogy drogháború van gyakorlatilag ennek
ellenére abszolút
nem tehát h ezért mondanám azt hogy hogy
jánbor emberek tehát jóra való
jámboremberek ez a ez a ez ami a
végső gondolatom róluk mindenhol mindig
segítőkészek voltak ha tetszik ez az
epizód akkor kérlek iratkozz fel a
csatornánkra vagy írd meg komment hogy
milyen más témáról hallanál még szívesen
a köszönöm a a a amikor elolvastam
ezeket a beszámolókat akkor éreztem hogy
ez egy nagyon jó beszélgetés lesz
ugyanis itt van mélyebben valami amit
meg szeretnék érteni és kíváncsi vagyok
így hogy mi lesz erre a válaszod úgy
ahogy le is írtad ebbe a beszámolóba
hogy nem a kulináris élvezetek hajtottak
oda és és nem is turistaként mentél oda
sőt olyan helyeken jártatok ahova még a
helyiek se mennek teljesen érintetlen
területekre és nem is a békák hajtottak
oda nem a nem a nem azért mentél oda
hogy hogy békákat néz hanem valami
mélyebben
mintogyha bennem ez fogalmazódott meg de
majd kijavíthatsz hogy lássam hogy jól
értem-e hogy miért mentél oda hogy
találkozz a
határaiddal találkozz az emberiség
határaival mert valójában amikor annyira
kimész a természetbe ahogy mondtad gps
nélkül egy öngyilkosság odamenni és
ennyire látni ezt a vad szépségét a
természetnek és eltávolodni mindentől a
családtól is ha kell azért hogy azért
hogy ezt a határt megízleld és utána
persze visszagyere de de mégis ebben van
egy egy egy
fontos fontos belső út te hogyan
fogalmaznád meg miért mentél oda hát ez
ez a jó kérdés amin egész végig rágódtam
mg mentem arra felé ültem a repülőn 14
órán volt arra hogy gondolkozak hogy
tényleg őszintén minek mert ugye
én régebb sokat utazgattam úgyhogy azért
láttam elég sok mindent úgyhogy annyira
nem jövök izgalomba ettől építészetileg
ecador nem egy nagy kaland kulinárisan
mint volt ráó szintén nem egy nagy
kaland és akkor felmerül a kérdés hogy
miért de azt hiszem hogy ez volt a ez a
végső válasz az egészre hogy hogy egy
kicsit megpróbáljam magamat hogy valóban
ennyire betokosodtam a hétköznapi
rutinomba valóban
ennyire kisvárosi emberré váltam aki aki
már nem akar kimozdulni már minden pont
jól van úgy ahogy van valóban elértem
azt a kort ahol az ember lezárja ügyesen
körbe az ajtócskákat egyen keresztül
járkál ki a nagyvilágba és azzal annyi
és és hogy ezt ezt szerettem volna
igazából megpróbálni ugyanakkor meg
nyilván
a
maga a természet az az tényleg
borzasztóan látványos borzasztóan
látványos micsoda kifejezés tehát hogy
hogy nagyon látványos az az azt hiszem a
borzasztó szónak is helye van mert ahogy
leírtad ez egy egyszerre gyilkos és
egyszerre gyönörű igen igen igen igen
igen igen tehát a meredek hegyoldalak az
egy idő után rutinná válik de az első
igazi ilyen hegymászós tehát ah ahol
tényleg meredeken kellett fölmenni azért
nagyon nézegettem hogy hű ha ennek nem
lesz jó vége persze kialakult
visszatérve hogy miért a a választ a mai
napig nem
tudom
megfogalmazni de hogy hogy ez volt az
alapgondolat hogy hogy akkor egy kicsit
kicsit
belepiszkálják abba a hamuba ami ott a
tűzhelyben van hogy alatta még van-e
valami parás valami még mozog-e bennem
hál istennek úgy érzem hogy igen tehát
hogy még
[Zene]
hogy hogy még nem akarom lezárni az
életemet nem akarom
teljessé teljesként elfogadni hogy akkor
oké eddig volt ez így szépen körbe van
minden falazva hanem tovább tovább még
több hülyeséggel kell foglalkozni mert
ez frissen tart mert mert hogyha ha ha
megállunk és és
ogadunk merev korlátokat akkor akkor
nagyon gyorsan megvénülünk nyilván ez
nem azt jelenti hogy mindenki akkor
adabnál v adab helyekre kell elmenni ezt
a egyszerű hétköznapokban nagyon jól
lehet követni udvarhelyen meg pláné
tehát hogy hogy itt van van amit látni
csak ugye nézni kell tehát gyakorlatilag
azt mondod hogy mindenki a saját
kontextusában meg tudja kapni azt ami
pont a határát súrolja egy picit túlmegy
azon amit éppen lehetségesnek tart
pontosan hány hete jöttél haza
ez assiszem az ötödik hét igen ez az
ötödik hét assiszem mi hát ez nagyon
furcsa nagyon furcsa érzés még az előző
gondolathoz valamit hozzá szeretnék
fűzni hogy amikor ugye egy hirtelen
felindulásbó lefoglaltam a repülőjegyet
meg ottan ment az egyezkedés akkor arra
gondoltam ugyanez a kérdés minek tényleg
őszintén már nem vagyok annyira ifjonti
hévvel teli hősöcske hogy akkor most
nekivágok hanem minek hogyha megfog egy
ekvadorit áthozzuk udvarhelyre és
udvarhelyről megfogunk egy udvarhelyt és
átvisszük eekvadorra ba és ottan másfél
hónapot él az egyik és a másik is
elkerülhetetlen hogy előbb-utóbb rutinná
válik neki az a környezet ahol van az a
kérdés hogy ezen a rutinon fölül van-e
valami van-e valami amit tud ajánlani
udvarhely vagy akkor ugye ebben az
esetben ecvador én ezt keresem és tudom
hogy udvarhely a rutinon fölül tud adni
nagyon sokat tehát egy egy egy egy olyan
vasárnapi séta
amikor amikor nem nagyon járnak az autók
mikor szépen süt a nap vagy mikor szépek
a felhők az hatalmas felüdelés ebbe a
városb úgyhogy de ne siessünk erről a
témáról el egy másik témáról mert ez egy
pont ez az amiről akartam beszélgetni
hogy mi az amit hoztál ecvadorból ahogy
másképp látod udvarhelyet ez például egy
dolog amit meg megfogalmaztál hogy
végigolvasva ezt a a naplót azt láttam
hogy ez egy áldás amit nem veszünk észre
a nap mint nap áldás hogy nem nedves
gumicsizmába kell menjünk és és az hogy
hogy létezik olyan hogy napsütés és
létezik olyan hogy hatalmas felhőket
látunk az égen és gyönyörű napsütés
mellett tudunk sétálni és a a
környezetünk nem akar megölni minden
pillanatban
persze vannak itt is vadabb környékek de
eekvadorba így ahogy elolvastam ez ez
tényleg egy hihetetlen biodiverzitással
és veszélyekkel
rendelkező hely lehetett úgyhogy még
van-e valami amit így az elmúlt öt
hétben így lassan megfogalmaztál
magadban mi az aminek aminek örvendenünk
kell mit udvarhelyieknek hú mindennek
gyakorlatilag nem is fogjuk fel hogy
milyen hihetetlen módon elkényeztetettek
vagyunk mi itt udvarhely konkrétan
udvarhely
európa románia is ö de hogy
udvarhely egyszerűen szerintem a
tökéletes hely persze borzasztóan
lokálpatrióta vagyok ez is beszél
belőlem de hogyha elkezdjük kielemezni
azt hogy mit tud ez a város nyújtani
akkor illetve felírjuk egy lapra akkor
mérlegeljük hogy akkor mi a pro mi a
kontra nem igazán tudok kontrát mondani
nem igazán tudok olyat mondani amire a
azt mondanám hogy na ezért nem élnék
udvarhelyen tehát nincs ilyen számomra
nincs ilyen és
te ha jól értettem csíki vagy nem tehát
te is gondolom hogy most már félig udvar
hát igen bocsánat hogy nem így akartam
ezt megfogalmazni kicsit mellé lépett a
gondolatom hogy hogy
ugyanúgy te is ki tudod elemezni
valamilyen szinten külső szemmel hogy
hogy mi van udvarhelyben amire az ember
azt mondja hogy hú nagyon szívesen érnék
udvarhelyen de á tehát nincs nincs ilyen
csak pozitív dolgokat tudok felsorolni
nyilván vannak ked borzolóbb dolgok meg
de ezek ezeket hogyha ha egy hosszútávú
görbén vizsgáljuk ezek fej se tűnnek
tehát ugye a nem akarok semmi
konkrétumot kiemelni de hogy hogy vannak
olyan dolgok amire az ember egyet mordul
de nem mondhatnám azt hogy hogy
folyamatosan van valami ami ami ami böki
a fejünket nincs ilyen ebben a városban
nincs ilyen mondom a lokálpatri itizmus
beszél belőlem de ugyanakkor meg
azt kell mondjam hogy a az erővonalak
tökéletes találkozásán van ez a van ez a
van ez a város mindig is érdekelt az
hogy miért élünk itt már úgy értem hogy
vhely nagyon régóta lakott miért hogyan
alakult mitől mi mi az ami az embereket
itt tartja megfogalmazza vagy hogy
megfogja őket
mivelaren születtem én egyszerűen
válaszolok erre a dolgokra én én én
teljesen meg vagyok örülve ezér őrülve
ezért a városét tehát abszolút szerelmes
vagyok
bené aki ide költözik máshonnan úgy
hozza az élete család akármi ők is
biztos meg tudják mondani ezt erre a
választ de a vége csak az hogy ez egy
tökéletes város mint olyan szoktam
mondani azt hogy nagy valószínűséggel ez
azért van mert valahol a budvár alatt
van egy hatalmas nagy barlang rendzer
hogy konteokról beszéljünk és akkor
ebben van egy óriási kristály amelyik
lebeg és ez minket itt tart és csendes
vasárnapi délutánokon lehet hallani hogy
ahogy zúg ez a kristály persze ez
hülyeség nyilván tehát ez csak egy poén
akar
lenni de hogy hogy megfogalmazhatatlan
hogy mi az ami itt tart minket addig
amíg el nem mentünk vissza nem
jöttünk én az ez egy nagyon fontos elem
amit mondtál egyrészt az hogy ha
megfogalmaz hatatlan valami attól még
érdemes róla beszélni mert lehet hogy
egy fél óra vagy akár másfél óra
beszélgetés utána egy lépéssel közelebb
kerülünk a ami párhuzam az életünkbe az
az hogy emlékszem én én amúgy én
kolozsváron végeztem az egyetemet nagyon
elvágytam cik szeredából azt akartam
hogy világot lássak és utána elmentem
brüsszelbe végeztem a mesteri képzésemet
és onnan eljutottam nepálba hat hetet
töltöttem én is nepálba és amikor akor
emlékszem a brüsszeli évekre amikor
visszaköltöztem mindig olyan érzésem
volt hogy na ebbe a porfészekbe költözök
vissza hogy én én utazni akarok én én
szabadulni akarok és a hat hét nepal
most ennyi év után vagy tizenpár éve
voltam ott hat hét nepallnak a fő
üzenete számomra az volt hogy amikor
visszajöttem bukarestbe szinte
megcsókoltam a vonatot amikor láttam az
és és annyira rendezettnek békésnek és
civilizáltnak tűnt románia nepálhoz
képest ott ahol hét évvel azelőtt
polgárháború volt egymás gyilkolták a
hihetetlenül sok gyermek maradt az utcán
it tapintható volt az a az amit te
mondtál a a a tájról a tájnak a
nyersessége én én tapintottam ki ki
kitapintható volt a a nepáli népnek a
szívébe az a fájdalom az a az a a a
durvaság az a sok árvaagyermek aki ott
maradt
és és visszajönni én is úgy jöttem
vissza vagy bocsánat én úgy jöttem
vissza hogy teljesen lokál patrióta
lettem teljesen
oda vagyok udvarhelyér és csíkér és
igazából nincs különbség csík és
udvarhely között ilyen távolságból
inkább a régió assiszem az ami
meghatározó
igen valami még f fogalmazódott-e meg
benned ezekhez képest én is ugyanezekre
a következtetésekre jutottam hogy
hihetetlenül áldottak vagyunk itt és
hihetetlenül sok potenciál vesz körbe
minket az a
amin mivel lokál patrióta vagyok őrült
módon tehát hogy radikális lokál
patrióta szinte azt kell mondjam
ami amin elgondolkoztam hogy rendben van
ez így ebben a formájában ez a buborék
amiben élünk és és kizárjuk a a
körülöttünk lévő világot tehát úgy
csinálun mintha nem létezne udvarra ez a
hely amit kikerül az internet ami ami
van ez a különleges erőtere az egésznek
az emberek fejébe ez a kristály miatt
nyilván hát persze és és a legjobb hogy
a kristály az a legújabb kutatások
szerint az szejkely borvízben úszik és
én elkövettem felelőtlen apaként azt a
hibát hogy a gyerekeim mikor kicsik
voltak akkor szejkely borvizet itadtam
velük úgyhogy ők már biztos hogy nem
fognak szabadulni innen mindenkinek a
szívében ott van a lánc ami ami oda köt
a nekem nem egy lánc hanem csak két
láncem így kapaszkodik egymásba tehát én
én én ebből a városból nem tudok ellenni
máshova úgyhogy ezért nagyon
foglalkoztat az hogy mi ennek a
rendszernek az alapja hogyan al alakult
ki mi az ami meg tudja tartani ezt a
rendszert és mi az amit a gyerekeinkre
az elkövetkezendő generációra
hátrahagyunk hogy hogy hogy ők is meg
tudják tartani tehát ez egy ez egy ez
egy anomália hogy udvarhely létezik
miért tartod anomáliának azért mertogy
ha ha körülnézel a világba mik történnek
milyen gazdasági változások vannak
milyen geopolitikai változ ások vannak
ugye általában hogy a a a földön élő
emberek hány százaléka nevezheti annyira
szerencsésnek magát mint mi akkor akkor
az az embernek az érzése hogy ennek
nagyon-nagyon kicsi a valószínűsége hogy
udvarhely ebben a formájában így
létezzen és az ai persze ez egy
sarkított dolog tehát nyilván meg
magánvélemény
de az a kérdés hogy ez mitől van illetve
az a kérdés hogy ezt ha ha meg ha nem is
tudjuk hogy mitől van hogyan tudnánk
fenntartani én meg vagyok győződve hogy
a a udvarhely megmaradásának a záloga a
jövőjének a záloga azok az élmények amik
idekötnek minket
én a 90-es évek gyereke vagyok
rengeteg 90-es években udvarhelyének
nagyon erős volt a
kocsmakultúrája
ami nem szeretném promoválni nyilván az
alkoholizmust de hogy ezek a kapcsolatok
amik akkor és ott kialakultak azok a
négy évek amit az emberek eltöltöttek
középiskolákban itt azok olyan erős
kötelékeket hoztak létre amit ha el is
költözik valaki a városból csak megmarad
benne nem nem egy útállat marad nem egy
olyan hú hálistennek elköltöztem onnan
hanem hanem egy egyfajta kötelék és és
ezt a köteléket kell valahogy valahogy
továbbadjuk hogy hogy
több módszer van
erre de de hogy melyik utat válasszuk az
az az megint megint a városnak a a
döntése én meg vagyok győződve arról
hogy az oktatás nagyon-nagyon fontos
ingyen és jó minőségű hozzáférhető
oktatás mindenféle területen
akkor a a másik az hogy tudatosítsuk a
gyerekeinkbe azt hogy hogy ez nem egy
nem egy default nem egy nem egy nem egy
alapadottság hogy van ez a város ennek
ennek oka van és hogy ezen dolgozni kell
és hogy a a a harmadik ami nagyon fontos
a
közösségépítés tehát ezt a várost a
közösségek tartják egybe alakították ki
én szerintem és
és folyamatosan ezen kell törekedjünk
hogy hogy új közösségek jöjjenek létre a
régiek megerősödjenek hogy az emberek
érezzék hogy ide tartoznak mindegy hogy
hogy hogy hol születtek honnan jöttek az
udvarhelyi az egy számomra egy fogalom
egy mentális állapot hogyha meg akarom
fogalmazni ez ez nagyon tetszik amit
megfogalmaztál ezen a szálon tovább
mennék de a hallgatók kedvéért azért
elmondom hogy érdemes komolyan venni
téged ugyanis tudom hogy hogy szeretsz
játszani de azt hiszem hogy a a
felnőttek játékát szereted játszani ahol
ahol van következménye é súlya is a
tetteidnek én ezt azért mondom mert
látom rajtad azokat amiket megemlítettél
hogy legyen egy oktatás hogy
generációkban gondolkozol és közösségben
gyakorlatilag ezt is csinálod egy kicsit
beszéljünk erről az oldaladról is amikor
ahol ahol fiatalokkal foglalkozol
tanítod őket és ugyan ez történik egy
ingyenes adomány az életedből az idődet
nem adja vissza senki tehát hogy azt
amit oda belefektettél nagyon meg kell
gondold hogy majd ők majd ők tovább
adják de ezt ezt nem véletlenül teszed
hanem hanem ami gyakorlatilag ez a
crédót hogy udvarhely egy egy élmény egy
élményeknek az összességbez te is hozzá
egy mentális állapot amihez te is
hozzátettél és teszel kicsit mesélsz
erről a kezdeményezéseidről mert
gondolom hogy több is van a háttérben
igen tehát a a heuréka alapsegítségével
tehát a székelyudvarai közösség
alapítványnak van egy heurrika programja
megragadom a galád módon most itt a
reklámhelyét mindenkinek ajánlom hogy
vegyen részt benne tanárok olyan emberek
akik általában oktatással foglalkoznak
mertogy ez egy ez egy nagyszerű
rendszer tehát ezen keresztül oktatok
gyerekeknek 3d-t egész konkrétan a
blender programot tanítom ami eg
ingyenes kisgépigényű könnyen
hozzáférhet ő nagyon felhasználó barát
nagyon fejlődő szoftvz tehát látványosan
fejlődik most a legutóbbi verzióval
olyan technológiai újításokat vezettek
be
amiket amik ezt a programot a a az ipari
szoftverek szintjére emeli és tehát e
mit lehet ezzel a blenderrel csinálni ha
ezt a tudá gyakorlatilag
mindent modellező ez egy mod olyan mint
az archicad vagy az autocad nem
mert tehát hogy lehet vele modelezni
animálni van egy játék engine modulja is
amit szintén fejlesztenek lehet benne
skultolni ami tehát hogy
digitális digitális szobrázkodni
gyakorlatilag
végtelen lehetőségek tárháza és utána
például 3d-s nyomtatóval ezeket ki lehet
nyomtatni igen igen a másik ami hogy
hogy lehet ugye 3d-s nyomtatóval
de bármien tehát hogyha valaki
építészettel szeretne foglalkozni akkor
azt a azt a részét ha valaki animációval
szeretne foglni azt a részét
konceptártal akkor azt a részét van egy
kőds része is tehát hogy kettőd-s
rajzfilmet is lehet vele csinálni ugye
általában egy tökéletes pont ahol be
lehet lépni úgy a 3d világába mint
mondtam alacsony gépigényű könnyen
érthető felhasználó barát pont ezek
kellenek a gyerekeknek mert én úgy
vagyok vele hogy azért szeretném ezt a
tudást tovább adni a gyerekeknek meg
azért szeretném őket erre tanítani mert
az a néhány közülük aki úgy érzi hogy
hoppá ez az és szerencsére vannak is
ilyenek ez az ami engem érdekel neki ez
egy egy lehetőség a jövőre való
tekintettel tehát egy egy pén egy egy
karrierlehetőség egy olyan karrier
lehetőség ami nem kell elmenni ebből a
városból pontosabban hogy el kell menni
ebből a városból de vissza lehet jönni
és lehet itthon élni ez eg ez egy nagyon
jó kitérő mindjárt erre rá fogok
kérdezni de megemlítettél egy címszót
ami amire kíváncsi vagyok hogy miért így
mondtad hogy ingyenes legyen az oktatás
ezt azért is kérdem mert manapság ebben
a világban ha valami ingyenes az egy
kicsit gyanút keltő tehát hogyha a
facebook ingyenes ha a google ingyenes
ha mert mer valójában nincs semmi ingyen
és
miért tartod fontosnak hogy kiemeld azt
hogy ingyenes és a blender hogyan tud
ingyenes lenni ez a másik
kérdésem ez hogy ingyenes maga ez az
oktatás amit például én is végzek ez
valóban ahogy mondod nincs semmi nincs
ingyen ezért ők fizetnek csak nem
pénzben hanem azzal fizetnek hogy hogy
fenntartják bennem a reményt hogy majd
később ennek a városnak szerves részei
lesznek tehát a ők a reménnyel fizetnek
nekem gyakorlatilag hogyha így
közelítjük meg a dolgot tehát hogy
ugyanez vonatkozik a blenderre is a
blender azért ingyenes mivel hogy egy
olyan lehetőséget kínál
a az emberek számára
ami amivel nagyon sokan élnek is és és
ezért ezt az egész dolgot előreviszik ők
visszatérnek
támogatják a tehát nagyon erős nagyon
erős közösséget hoznak létre és
támogatják a szoftvert ez a kezdeti
közösségi támogatás ez odáig vitte a
dolgot hogy jelenleg nagyon nagy cégek
nagyon nagy összegekkel támogatják a
blendert és továbbra is ugyanazé az
emberé a blender aki volt az elején és
majd már van egy kész jogi struktúra
erre hogy majd teljesen open tehát
jelenleg is open source de hogy a jövőre
való tekintettel hogy ne lehess
megvásárolni hogy ez ez mindig is
ingyenes legyen azért tartom fontosnak
azt hogy ingyenes legyen mertogy mertogy
mindannyian ugye óriások válán állunk
tehát a a az előttünk járó emberek
tudását nem lehet eladni vagy az olyan
kicsit milyen dolog és és ez ez itt
érvényesül is a a blendernél valóban ez
amit mondtál hogy ha valami ingyenes
akkor az gyanút keltő én ezt nem is
vitatom de ugyan an akkor azt is
figyelembe k kell venni hogy nem
mindenért pénzzel fizetünk sőt a dolgok
túlnyomó többségéért nem pénzzel
fizetünk az időnkér fizetünk az
elkötelezettségünkért fizetünk a a
hitünkért fizetünk sok mindenért és és
ilyen értelemben ez ezért a szoftverért
meg általában az oktatásért valóban
fizetünk
igen hát a a az ignis kapcsán látom hogy
mennyibe kerül az oktatás hogy valójában
mennyibe kerül az hogy hogy két
munkatárssal együtt tudjuk megálmodni a
a a különböző képzéseket hogy a
fiataloknak ingyenes vagy pedig nagyon
olcsón oktatási
modulokat tudjunk kidolgozni és ez
fogalmazódott meg bennem ez ez a
kettőnek az ellentétje hogy amúgy a
román rendszerben az oktatás ingyenes
idézőjelben de hihetetlen mennyiségű
pénzbe kerül azért hogy fenntartsuk ezt
a komplex infrastruktúrát és valójában
az adófizető kemény en dolgoznak és
mégis megéri megéri mert a tudás ennyit
ér még ha nem is hatékony még hogyha min
1zerféle kritikát tudunk megfogalmazni
vele kapcsolatban mégis megéri nekem ami
tetszik az az hogy lehető van benned
kritika én nem hallottam tőled de a
válaszod erre nem egy passzív harag és
keserűség hanem konkrétan az hogy mész
és teszel valamit és a az álmodozó
művészeknek a sorából emiatt
lógsz ki számomra hogy nem egy álmodozó
művész vagy hanem hanem egy
cselekvőművész vagy számomra amelyik
tesz is a dolgokér és
konkrétan a tettei és a szavai
szinkronban vannak egymással
a nem tudom hogy valamit ehhez fűznél-e
hozzá ha nem akkor lenne egy következő
kérdés nem ez
a művész megfogalmazást azt úgy nagyon
próbálom távol tartani magamtól miért
mertogy
merthogy nem tekintem magamat
hagyományos értelemben vett művésznek
mint olyan nekem ezek hogy rajz
hagyományos
művész nem tudok belemenni ebbe a
vonalba anélkül hogy ne fogalmaznék meg
emberek számára sértő gondolatokat
úgyhogy ezt inkább passzolom de hogy
hogy nekem minden amit amit megtanultam
vagy amivel foglalkozok ezek mind mind
eszközként tekintek ezekre a dolgokra
pontosan tehát a a számomra a művész
hogyha egy definíciót kellene mondani
számomra a művész az aki a világnak a
végtelen komplexitásából összegyűjt
különböző dolgokat és összegyúrja gyúrja
egy új identitássá amit azelőtt nem
látott ott volt de más nem látott és ezt
meg lehet sokféleképpen csinálni de de
művészet számomra az amikor amikor
rájövök arra hogy ezt azért látom
másképpen mert azelőtt valaki órákat 100
órákat ha kell tölt töltött töltött
valaminek a a megalkotásával úgyhogy
számomra a művészet aki igazán a
művészettel foglalkozik az egy ez egy
nagyon izgalmas és becsülendő dolog
tehát nekem amúgy ez egy ez egy bók volt
a te irányodban hogy művésznek látlak
mert összerakni ezt a tehát például ezt
az utin naplót ez számomra azért volt
művészé mert egyszerre volt egy grafikai
eleme egyszerre volt egy egy írott
formája ami amúgy nagyon izgalmas tehát
hogyha az emberek elolvassák akkor látni
fogják hogy szórakoztató de mégis minden
bekezdésben van egy gondolat ami úgy
elindít egy újabb gondolatot és emellett
pedig ott van a fizikai kaland is amiben
részt vettél és talán ez lenne a
következő kérdésem és lehet hogy ebben
a nem utolsó nem utolsó mert még lesz
egy kérdésem de az utolsó közötti
kérdésem az az hogy miért tartod
fontosnak hogy valaki elköltözzön
elmenjen és utána visszajöjjön mert így
fogalmaztál hogy el kell menni így van
azért kell elmenni ebből a városból hogy
az ember megtapasztalja hogy miért kell
ebben a városban élni tehát erre a a
fiam ő ugye tíédzser korosztály ha
visszaemlékszek a saját
ttinnédzserkoromra volt bennem mind
mindenkiben hál istennek egyfajta
lázadás nyilván ez kell konfrontálódnunk
kell ha elfogadjuk a dolgokat úgy ahogy
vannak az nem vezet jóra tehát mindig
konfrontálódnunk kell az előttünk jááró
generációval a szüleinkkel a
környezetünkkel bármilyen gondolattal
amivel találkozunk mindennel
konfrontálódnunk kell mert ebből
származnak a kérdések ezekből a
kérdésekből lesznek azok a válaszok
amikre majd később tudunk
építkezni ilyen szempontból az aki
udvarhelyen született udvarhelyen nőtt
fel az azért kell elmenjen udvarhelyről
mert kell konfrontálódjon ezzel a
várossal és ez nagyon gyorsan meg is
történik mert hogyha most összevetjük
egy kolozsvári élettel csak ami nem
nincs is olyan messzire udvarhely egy
álmos kisváros maximum és akkor most
nagyon megdicsértem főleg mostanában
ugye
a a kocsmai élet
ami egyfajta közösségi élet is azért
eléggé lefelé tartó ágában van de
szerintem ez változni fog hamarosan
reméljük és azért kell elmenni ebből a
városból hogy megtapasztaljunk
megismerjünk mindenfélét hogy mikor
visszajöjünk akkor lássuk ebből a
kontrasztból hogy egy hogy milyen
hatalmasan szerencsések vagyunk kettő
pedig a tanult dolgokat itthon
érvényesítsük nyilván és erre nagyon sok
példa van ebben a városban nagyon sok
olyan vendéglátóipari egység ami ami így
lett hogy valaki elment külföldre
dolgozott kínlódott
küzdött hazajött abból nagyon
sok olyan tehát it szektorban dolgozó
van aki elment külföldön dolgozott
konfrontálódott hazajött és és itthon
próbálja ezt atztatni tehát nagyon nagy
szüksége van a városnak erre a fajta
folyamatos konfrontációra de ez amúgy
nagyon érdekes ez a dinamika hogy a
például a katedrálisokban sokszor van
egy olyan mozaikszerű ilyen labirintus
ahonnan a közepéből indulsz és elmész
tehát gyakorlatilag olyan mint egy
keresztés vagy egy keresztalakja van és
északra délre keletre és nyugatra mész
végig követve a labirintus útját és a
végén amikor megérkezel valójában pont
odaérrkezel ahonnan elindultál és ez ez
ez egy mély minta ez a tékozló fiúnak a
története ahol elmegy és visszaajön
ugyanoda jön vissza de már más emberként
jön vissza ez a te utad is valójában
ecuadorba ahogy miniatűrbe
reprezentáltad hogy elmentél és
visszajöttél már sokszor elmentél és
sokszor visszajöttél de ez most egy
mélyebb szinten történt azt hiszem hogy
ez ez ez egy ez egy jó dolog hogy hogy
apaként bátorítsuk a gyermekeinket én is
három gyerekes csaláldapaként ez a
tervem hogy bátorítsam őket arra hogy
feszüljenek neki a világnak menjenek
harcoljanak tanulják meg hogy milyen a
világban élni és majd jöjjenek vissza ez
a sárkányölőszentgyőy története menj és
öld meg azt a sárkányt mert a sárkánynak
mindig van egy kincse amit ha
visszahozol szét tudod osztani az
emberek között én ezt kicsit inkább úgy
látom hogyha elég sokáig vagyunk a
színpadon akkor akkor minden szerepet
kiosztanak tehát az ifjú lázadó
anakimból előbb-utóbb az az ember eljut
pálpatin császárig
ahogy halad előre tehát és válaszokat
talál arra hogy a szüleink miért mondtak
bizonyos dolgokat nekünk miért próbáltak
bizonyos irányokba terelni minket és
ugyanezekkel a konfliktusokkal
szembemegyünk a saját gyerekeinkkel is
ezért mondom hogy hogy nem tudunk
öröklázadók maradni hanem ott kell
legyünk ott kell legyünk hogy legyen
valaki akik ellen majd rázadnak ayerek
ehát hog ez ez ajta folyamatos körforgás
ez ez is egy nagyon erős hajtó rugója
ennek a városnak és alázatraint és
alázatraint hogy nem önmagunknak éljünk
hanem egy nván nván a hogy mondtad
óriások vállán állunk mindannyian és
hálásak kell legyünk hogy ott vagyunk az
óriások válán és egy kicsit megemelni a
szintet hogy a következő generáció egy
picivel magasabban
álljon hát nyilván ebbe az irányba
kellene juk ezt a ezt az egészet hogy ha
nem is magasabban de de hogy megértsék
azt hogy hogy hogy miért történnek ezek
a dolgok gondold emelni nem tudsz ezen a
szinten én úgy érzem hogy nem
feltétlenül az a célom hogy emeljem ezt
a szintet bőségesen elég nekem az hogy
hogyha ha nulla fölé egy halványvonallal
a már
tehát hogy ez igen igen igen tehát hogy
hogyha nem ereszkedik a dolog akkor már
nagyon jól vagyunk nyilván é én azt
látom hogy feladatunk az hogy emeljünk
de legyünk azzal is tisztában hogy ha
kőkeményen vérrel verejtékkel az egész
életünket nekiszentelve
egy aranyeszközzé csiszoljuk magunkat
akkor egy kicsit egy hajszálnyival
fogjuk tudni emelni ennyire értékes az
amit kaptunk örökül az előző
generációktól és ennyire alázatosan kell
hozzáálljunk a a reform az
újraformáláshoz a
reformhoz
még vannak-e hasonló kezdeményezés
kzdeményezéseid még amiről esetleg
mesélnél említetted ezt a popup könyvet
ez ez egyik gondolom a többi közül de
van-e kedved erről meséljni vagy valami
másról
hát különösebben igazából azt a pop-up
könyven ami ami ami visszaköszön az hogy
hogyan történnek a dolgok az életemben
miért nem szeretem azt hogy hogyha
valamilyen kategóriába
besorolnak nem azért mert hű de milyen
borzasztóan különleges vagyok ez tával
álljon tőlem egy egyszerű közember
vagyok
hanem általában az van hogy hogy valami
elkezd érdekelni jellemzően teljesen
párhuzamos azzal mint amivel addig
foglalkoztam és és akkor ezeknek utána
ások utána túrok
van amikor ezek teljesen elsikkadnak nem
lesz belőlük semmi van amikor meg önjáró
projekté válnak egyszer csak azon kapom
magamat egyik pillanatról a másikra hogy
csak ezzel foglalkozok csak ez érdekel
csak errő tudok beszélni csak ezt akarom
csúcsra járatni a popup könyv is egy egy
ilyen dolog volt egy egy éjszaka
összeraktam az egyik modellt nézegettem
hogy hűha azta mekkora cucc
és le is zártam volna de akkor jött a
következő gondolat a következő gondolat
a következő gondolat és egyszer csak
azon kaptam magamat hogy akkor
megcsináltam ezt a könyvet de ez is
addig érdekel amíg amíg úgy érzem hogy
eljutok benne arra szintre ahol én én
meg vagyok elégedve vele akkor általában
valami valami újra hát már majd menet
közben valami új dolog köszönt be ezért
nem tudom megfogalmazni
egy szóba hogy akkor az mi is még milyen
ilyen kalandjaid voltak hát
most így
hirtelen tehát hogy hogy ilyen projektek
ilyen projektek amikor valami
megszületik benned egy nagy lángal neki
fogsz valamit csináltál t ez például a a
vr
a headsetek meg ez egész az egész vr
technológia a ennek kapcsán ugye az
unreal engine-nek a a megtanulása abba
utána túrni hogy hogy történnek a dolgok
mit hogy kell csinálni amúgy blender
modelleket lehet használni vizualizálni
persze persze ez az
alapelképzelés az egészben hogy azért
kellene megtanítani a gyerekeket 3d-ben
dolgozni mertogy ezzel meg tudnak egy eg
csomó mindent
jeleníteni ki tudják fejezni a
gondolataikat ha volt olyan diákom vagy
olyan valaki aki aki effektíven egy egy
hosszabb animációt csinált ami egy saját
gondolat mentén volt kialakítva volt
olyan aki aki a modelezés fogott meg és
ezt felhasználta gyakorlatban tehát egy
szoba tervezéséhez
úgyhogy
úgyhogy az ezért ezért tartom nagyon
fontosnak ezt meg
ezek erről
vitatkozhatnánk a azokkal az emberekkel
akik szintén 3d-vel foglalkoznak ezek a
technológiák az unreal engine és a
blender ez két olyan technológia ami ami
abszolút meg fogja határozni a
jövőt nagyon-nagyon sok téren mertogy
mertogy úgy tűnik hogy az unreal
engine-nek az alapelképzelése az hogy
egy szoftver minden fölött ez ez egyre
inkább megvalósulni látszik és
ezzel lépést kell tartani minden techn
mostani modern játékok jó része ebbe az
unreal enginebe í készül még mi az a
mikért használják az unreal engine íg íg
hát
gyakorlatilag mindenre filmek igen igen
tehát például most a mandaloriá ugye a a
star wars sorozat az unreal engineben
készült a az egésznek a háttere üüm
tehát háttérmunka ö
tehát lehet használni játékkészítésre
lehet használni szimulációkra lehet
használni animációra lehet használni
most már tud modelezni is
akkor nagyon érdekes
[Zene]
dolgokat lehet
megvalósítani például egy egy olyan
projekt ami felé már egy darab ideje
kacsintgatok aztán hogy eljutoke oda az
egy másik kérdés úgy nevezik hogy
digital twin tehát hogy egy városról
csinálnak egy egy egy digitális
másolatot gyakorlatilag unreal engineben
ami azért érdekes maguk az épületek nem
feltétlenül hanem hanem egy ilyen
digital twinbe nagyon sok szimulációt le
lehet futtatni udvarhelynek például a ha
egy meteorit becsapna akkor nem nem nem
nem nem egyszerű dolgok a forgalom
például a forgalom forgalom tehát hogy
ezt
udvarhelynek készítettél már ilyen
modell még nem jutottam el idáig ez egy
következő ö nekem az van hogy
a számítógépemen van egy csomó ilyen
majd ezzel is kellene foglal majd ezzel
is kellene foglalkozni úgyhogy ezzel
nincsen gond hogy milyen hülyeséggel
foglalkozzak idézőjelbe legközelebb
merthogy mindig mindig van valami amivel
amivel szeretnék foglalkozni remélem
hogy ez így lesz egy darabig és mi a
következő terved következő tervem most
jelenleg amin ami amibe jobban
beletúrtam magamat az ugye a blendernek
az animációs képességei
illetve egy olyan oktatási még még
mindig ez az oktatá egy olyan
oktatási rendszer a blenderhez ami ami
nagyon-nagyon kicsi kortól elérhető
tehát öt-h éves gyerek számára elérhető
megérthető mivel hogy a blendernek a
teljes felületét lehet programozni bele
lehet nyúlni és meg vagyok győződve
arról hogy lehet egy olyan
rendszert létrehozni amivel tényleg
nagyon-nagyon fiatalon már bele tudnak
kni így van anélkül hogy ők ők ezt ezt
tanulásként élnék meg tehát nem
játékként de hogy hogy hogy egy
érdekesség ez hogyha összekötjük a 3d-s
nyomtatókkal akkor egy olyan szettet
kapunk ami ami ami egy nagyon érdekes
utat nyit volt még egy korábbi
gondolatom csak azt elfelejtettem hogy
azért tartom fontosnak én a ugye ezt a
3ds dolgot értem úgy ahogy
én ezt tanítom mindenki ami amit ért ami
intellektuális dolog ami aggyal történik
azt kell tanítsa tanítsa mert meg vagyok
győződve hogy udvarhelynek a jövője ez
ez hogy mint mondtam udvarhelyinek lenni
az egy mentális állapot egy egy
hozzáállás az élethez ez a hozzáállás ez
ez
nagyon nagyon jól r értékesíthető csak
nem igazán fogjuk föl hogy mennyire is
nagyon jól értékesíthető ha megnézzük
azokat az udvarhelyeket akik elmentek
udvarhelyről és nyugaton bekerültek egy
egy nagyobb vállalathoz jellemzően
mindenki középvezető felső vezető tehát
hogy mindenki előre tudott törni mert
egy ilyen mindsetünk van egy ilyen egy
ilyen hozzáállásunk van a világhoz ez
egy ez egy nagyon értékes dolog amit
amit lehetne értékesíteni
udvarhely szintte
ehhez nyilván az kell hogy a
gyerekeinket úgy neveljük
föl hogy megerősítsük bennük ezt és és
ha el is mennek akkor mindig fontos
legyen nekik a kapcsolat a várossal hogy
akár tőkét hozzanak be a városba akár
tudást hozzanak be akár meghívottak
szintjén emelyik a városnak a a a
presztízsét tehát hogy ezért tartom
nagyon fontosnak azt hogy hogy hogy ne
ük a
gyerekeinket nyitsuk a modern
technológiák felé modern tudások felé
nyitsuk azért mert hogy ez ez lesz a
jövőnk záloga most már nem
reménykedhetünk abba ugye világszinten
sem hogy visszatér a a régi gyárrendszer
a a központosított gyártás mert ez már
nem létezik a turizmus az egy olyan egy
olyan kártyánk amit ugye el tudunk adni
ugye a szejkén a a miniérdély park ezt
nagyon jól csinálja
de ez ez mellé még kellenek dolgok
amivel tudjuk garantálni azt hogy az
emberek meg tudnak maradni ebben a
városban jelenleg
nem tudom hogy mi ez ami ami ami itt
tudja tartani az embereket úgy érzem
hogy hogy a az it szektor a
a a közgazdaság ezek ezek a ezek a
területek azok amikbe amikbe jók vagyunk
nyilván nem lehet mindenki közgazdás mer
megigen közgazdász meg it de ők hogyha
ha tőkét tudnak behozni a városba akkor
a többieknek is ugyanúgy jövőt
biztosítanak ez egy ilyen ködös jövőkép
elképzelésem hogy ez mennyire
megvalósítható ezt majd a jövő fogja
megmondani ha valaki szeretne neked
segíteni ez sok szülő és talán sok
gyermek is fogja hallani vagy több
ttinnédzser fogja hallani ezt a műsort
hogyan tudnának neked segíteni
hát tanuljanak blendert ez ezt tudom
mondani hogy különösebben azzal tudnak
segíteni hogy hogy megértik ezeket a
gondolatokat nekem ez egy nagy segítség
megértik ezeket a gondolatokat
hogy hogy miért olyan hatalmasan fontos
ez a város világszint tehát hogy életvit
nem világszinten rossz volt a kifejezés
hanem hogy hogy és hogy és hogy miért
kell biztosítsuk ennek a városnak a
jövőjét nem politikára gondolok
semmilyen módon hanem úgy általában az
életvitelünkkel ahogy hozzáállunk a
dolgokhoz ahogy ahogy ahogy ahogy
biztosítsuk ennek a városnak a jövőjét
ezzel tudnának asszem segíteni gyakor
köszönöm szépen hogy itt voltál számomra
nagyon izgalmas beszélgetés volt
sajnálom hogy az eekvadori történetet
kicsit nem sikerült jobban kiveséznem
hanem elmentem az udvarhelyi
lokálpatriotizmus irányába de ez is egy
olyan dolog számomra ami ami ami fontos
volt ebbe az eekuadori történetbe ez
maga az út volt és az hogy elmentél és
visszajöttél amiről viszont tudtunk
beszélgetni talán ecadorról kevesebbet
de talán téged se ecuador érdekelt
önmagában hanem hanem valami egyéb amit
amit úgy érzem hogy visszahoztál és
megtaláltál és a kedves nézőknek is
mondom hogy köszönöm hogy figyeltétek
ezt az adást hogyha szeretnétek hasonló
epizódokat hallani akkor a akkor
iratkozzatok fel a csatornánkra valamint
ennek a videónak a a lábjegyzetében majd
fogunk egy linket hagyni hogy hogy lehet
elérni ferencet hogyha valamilyen
szempontból í feliratkoznátok vagy
segítenétek a az ő munkáját szerintem
nagyon izgalmas dolgokkal foglalkozik
valamint osszátok meg ezt a videót
és és iratkozzatok fel a csatornánkra
mint ahogy mondtam köszönöm szépen hogy
itt voltál én köszönük szépen ha
tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz fel
kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni köszönjük a vker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre